digamos que tenemos la función que es
igual a y me tomo la función logaritmo
natural de x y todo esto lo elevó a la
potencia x
imagínate esta función y lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar la derivada de james
con respecto a x así que te invito a
pausar este vídeo y ver si puedes
lograrlo
bien cuando intentas abordar este tipo
de problemas puede ser que sea un poco
intimidante porque sabemos sacar la
derivada de una constante a la potencia
x pero como sacamos la derivada de algún
tipo de función en este caso la función
es logaritmo natural de x esto a la
potencia x y bueno la respuesta es que
vamos a usar algunas propiedades de los
logaritmos y luego vamos a hacer un poco
de diferenciación implícita así que qué
te parece un poquito esto y voy a
tomarme un poco más de espacio para que
todo salga perfecto así que voy a poner
porque nuestra función que era logaritmo
natural de x esto lo tenemos elevado a
la potencia x recuerdas bueno y lo
primero que voy a hacer es intentar
deshacerme de esta x como exponente y ya
que lo hagamos vamos a ser capaces de
aplicar la regla del producto de alguna
manera y la forma en la que puedo quitar
esta x como exponente es
aplicando la función logaritmo natural
de ambos lados el logaritmo natural de
esto es igual a logaritmo natural de
todo esto que tenemos aquí y seguramente
te estás preguntando bueno porque esto
podría ser útil y es que si estoy
sacando el logaritmo natural de algo que
está elevado a un cierto exponente
entonces esto va a ser igual si
recuerdas una de las propiedades de los
logaritmos puede ser que la recuerdes
puede ser que no pero hay una propiedad
básica de los logaritmos que dicen que
el logaritmo natural o bueno puede ser
el logaritmo de algo elevado a una
cierta potencia esto va a ser igual a la
potencia por el logaritmo natural de en
este caso a bueno es sólo una propiedad
de los logaritmos estándar y esta
propiedad nos va a ayudar a escribir
esto de la siguiente manera si sacamos
el logaritmo natural de ambos lados
entonces este exponente de aquí puede
llegar al frente y escalar todas
esta función entonces tendríamos el
logaritmo natural déjame ponerlo con
este color el logaritmo natural de 100
lo voy a poner con su respectivo color
esto va a ser igual y ahora voy a poner
primero esta x por esta propiedad de los
logaritmos a x veces quien bueno x veces
el logaritmo natural de de esta
expresión que tenemos adentro de el
logaritmo natural de x de el logaritmo
natural d
bien
y seguramente se sigue preguntando bueno
amigo pero cómo va a ser esto realmente
útil para nosotros y es que ahora
podemos hacer una diferenciación
implícita sacar la derivada con respecto
a x de ambos lados así que para eso
déjenme mover un poco esto que tengo
aquí para poder poner la diferenciación
implícita lo voy a mover un poco para
acá para tomarnos la derivada con
respecto a x de ambos lados entonces voy
a sacar la derivada con respecto a x
este lado y voy a hacer lo mismo para
este otro lado voy a sacar la derivada
con respecto a x de todo esto ok
ahora bien del lado izquierdo si
observas esta parte de aquí lo único que
tenemos que hacer es aplicar la regla de
la cadena porque cuando aprendes la
diferenciación implícita es sólo una
aplicación de la regla de la cadena es
la derivada de la función de afuera
en este caso el logaritmo natural de
jeff con respecto a la función de
adentro que es entonces la derivada de
el logaritmo natural de james con
respecto a james es uno entre entre
james
ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de la función interior esto con
respecto a x lo cual me va a dar la
derivada de james con respecto a x
ahora que tenemos del lado derecho del
lado derecho tengo está derivada que
tengo aquí simplemente hay que aplicar
la regla del producto vamos a tomarnos
la derivada con respecto a x de x de la
primera expresión lo cual bueno es
simplemente 1 la derivada de que son
respecto x es 1 por la segunda función
la cual es el logaritmo natural de bueno
de el logaritmo natural de x de el
logaritmo natural de x y a esto hay que
sumarle a esto hay que sumarle la
primera función tal cual
que multiplica a la derivada de la
segunda función o de la segunda
expresión así que nosotros queremos
saber cuánto es esta derivada déjame
ponerlo aquí quiero saber cuánto es la
derivada con respecto a x de el
logaritmo natural de el logaritmo
natural de el logaritmo natural de x
el logaritmo natural de x y bueno cuánto
va a ser la derivada de el logaritmo
natural de el lugar y natural de x bueno
pues esto es simplemente aplicar la
regla de la cadena de nuevo esto me va a
quedar igual y primero tengo la derivada
de el logaritmo natural con respecto a
la función interior entonces me va a
quedar 1 entre esta función 1 entre el
logaritmo natural de x el logaritmo
natural de x ok y esto a su vez hay que
multiplicarlo por la derivada de la
función interior y la derivada de el
logaritmo natural de x que es muy fácil
es uno entre x
así que esto va a ser igual y ahora lo
voy a poner con este color 1 / x por el
logaritmo natural de x muy bien ahora
puedo decir que la derivada de todo esto
que tenemos aquí es lo mismo que 1
/ x por el logaritmo natural d
muy bien y cómo se están multiplicando
está x y está x se cancelan y nos vamos
a quedar con dejen de utilizar este
color para todos nos vamos a quedar con
esta parte es lo mismo que uno entre y
que multiplica a la derivada de james
con respecto a x ok y toda esta parte es
lo mismo que bueno el logaritmo natural
de el logaritmo natural de x muy bien a
esto a su vez hay que sumarle uno entre
el logaritmo natural de x muy bien y
ahora para resolver para la derivada voy
a multiplicar de ambos lados por jeff
voy a multiplicar de este lado por james
y también de este lado porque de tal
manera que esta hierba y estalle se
cancelan y del lado izquierdo me queda
simplemente la derivada de james con
respecto a x ok
y del lado derecho me va a quedar bueno
recuerda quién era y que era nuestra
función original recuerda que james era
el logaritmo natural el logaritmo
natural de x esto elevado a la potencia
x así que del lado derecho me va a
quedar bueno déjame ponerlo así el
logaritmo natural de el logaritmo
natural de x ok a esto a su vez le
estamos sumando 1 entre el logaritmo
natural de x
no voy a distribuir esta función que
tenemos al final pero la voy a poner
aquí esto a su vez está multiplicando el
logaritmo natural de x esto elevado a la
potencia x esto elevado a la potencia x
y tal vez esto se vea un poco
desordenado pero ya obtuvimos la
derivada que buscábamos
así que supongamos que la pregunta
original era
encuentra la derivada de james con
respecto a x no sé
y se me ocurre poner en x igual a
ok estoy tomando este valor para que
podamos sustituirlo justo aquí en la
expresión a la que llegamos y entonces
en lugar de x voy a poner a m así que
aquí me va a quedar y aquí me va a
quedar y aquí me va a quedar y aquí
también me va a quedar y estoy
utilizando este valor de él porque es un
valor fácil de evaluar entonces me
quedaría el logaritmo natural de m bueno
esto es lo mismo que uno y después tengo
el logaritmo natural de uno bueno he
elevado a la potencia cero es 1 así que
todo esto me va a dar 0 más y aquí tengo
el logaritmo natural de m
esto ya dijimos que es 11 entre 1 es1 ok
entonces de todo esto de todo esto de
aquí me quedan simplemente 1
ok ya esto lo voy a multiplicar ok a
esto lo voy a multiplicar por y bueno
tengo el logaritmo natural de m
esto es 1 y 1 elevado a la potencia es
bueno 1 elevado a cualquier potencia es
simplemente 1 así que me va a quedar uno
por uno
si evaluó en x igual a lo cual es 1 esa
sería mi respuesta final de todo este
problema es por eso que quería que
evaluaremos en este valor escogí un
valor bastante sencillo porque pensé que
sería divertido nos vemos en el
siguiente